- Today, I'm spilling the tea on a topic
I know that many of you are interested in
and this is Heinrich's at
TierOne Consulting Firm
like McKinsey, BCG, or Bain.
So, welcome to another coffee break
here on my Channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich and as you know
on my Channel I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
And part of that is for
sure also understanding
what the salaries are that you
could potentially be earning
over the first years of your career.
And I wanna help you with
that with this video.
And specifically I will address
this in the following way.
So, we'll start with
providing some general remarks
and qualifications that are just important
to understand the numbers better
that I will now share
with you in a moment.
And then I will go over some
key roles, key positions
in the career track in the
TierOne Consulting Firm.
This is going to be the
business analyst role,
the associate role,
the project lead role
and the Partner role.
And I will discuss for each of these roles
what your salary expectations can be
if you work in such a TierOne Firm.
So, let's indeed start
with these qualifications.
And what's indeed important
to me here is that,
of course in this video, I
will not share specific numbers
of any specific Consulting Firm.
So, you know that I had a path at McKinsey
but I will not specifically
talk about McKinsey
but also consider friends
working at companies
like Boston Consulting or Bain
and take all their experiences
to provide you here a rough overview
of how all these consulting expectations
in TierOne Firms look like.
Next important point is that
salaries differ significantly
country by country, region by region.
The salaries of Germany might
be significantly different
from the salaries in let's
say Spain also U.K. or the U.S
so have this in mind in this video
we're specifically focused
on the situation in Germany
because I know that this is a region
that many of you are familiar with
and I trust that this will be informative
for people in other regions as well
but do your research for your region.
And if you're wondering
well how shall I do this?
How shall I find this
information for my country?
I created a course on salary negotiations
together with a good friend of mine
who is also a former consultant.
I will link this course below
in the video description.
And there's also full module
on the topic of salary research.
The trust that this will contain
some interesting insights.
Last but not least, I will
not talk about base salary.
So, the base salaries that
you would pretty much get
fixed independent of your performance.
On top of that most firms have also bonus
that they offer to you.
And this is really up to 20% or so.
So, if you're rated in the
highest performance category
this is what you can expect.
Of course, most people
will not get the highest rating et cetera,
performance rating which is about average
or slightly above average,
you can expect to get a bonus
which will roughly be
10% of your base salary.
So, this is what you should then add
on top to the numbers that
I will mention to you.
And then of course if you look at
the full compensation package,
most firms also offer
something like a company car
that you will get even
as a junior consultant.
And then there are other
benefits like insurances
or additional travel allowances
that will be provided to you
which you should add on
top of this base salary
that we will be discussing right now.
So, let's get into it and discuss
the individual roles in detail.
And while I will also provide
a direct characterization of the roles,
(mumbles) no idea how this works,
what the roles or responsibilities
of these different positions exactly are.
I created a full video
on that it was called
"How a Career in Consulting Looks Like"
and I will link it somewhere above here.
So, check this out if
this is all new to you
and you really wanna
understand a bit better
how the whole career path
in consulting looks like.
So, the first role I wanna talk about
is the business analyst role.
And how exactly these roles are called,
changes a bit firm by firm,
they all have their own terminology
though in the end is all the same, right?
And the business analyst role
is the role that you will
have fresh out of university.
If you need for university with
a bachelor or master degree
you just start out in consulting,
this is the role that you would have.
Of course, in this role you would usually
crunch the numbers, conduct
interviews with clients,
create slide decks.
So, this is really the role
where you learn the ropes of the trade.
And for this role in
a country like Germany
you can expect a salary of
roughly 70,000 Euro per year
for a master level
graduate, which is of course
a very decent starting
salary for a new graduate.
You will have this business
analyst role for about two years
and after two years most
of these TierOne Firms
offer something which is very unique
and this is the so-called leave program.
And here again how exactly it's called
differs a bit company by company
but what essentially it boils down to
is that the company will
give you the opportunity
to leave work again
and to spend some time to
conduct a PhD or an MBA
or often also social leave year
if you want to volunteer
for a social organization.
And this time, which usually
takes two to three years
we'll be heavily subsidized
by your employer.
So for instance, if you do an MBA
the company usually will sponsor
a significant portion of
the tuition of your MBA
and they will pay you money on top
often also up to a full salary
just to cover your living
expenses in this time.
And here even within the TierOne Firms
there can be significant differences
in how exactly this program is
set up, how attractive it is.
What I learned now from
talking to other friends
probably the McKinsey one is
arguably the most attractive
then followed by the Boston
Consulting followed by the Bain.
And here also what I
want you to understand
is that many of these
smaller two-tier firms
offer programs like this as well.
But then if you look into them off
they're not as attractive
or maybe they are saying,
yes, you can do that,
but then the end it turns out
that only if you're ranked
as one of the top top performers,
you will really be offered to do this.
And then the big majority
of consultants in the end
will not have this opportunity.
So, I'd argue that this
is really something
that on top of the
regular salary differences
really sets apart these tier-one firms
from these other firms
and you really should
take this into account
when you compare the
total compensation package
in the first years of
your time in consulting
because the value of
the compensation package
that you get in this leave program
can easily be in the six digits.
So, really have a look at this closely
before you ask yourself
what company you wanna join after all.
Then after the leave
usually you enter an
associate type of position.
This is also the position
that you would directly be able to join
if you join consulting
with an MBA or with a PhD.
In terms of the contents of your job
this is pretty much just an extension
of what you were doing
as a business analyst
with the only difference that
now more is expected from you.
So, you will be now expected
to lead larger parts of the project.
You will be expected now to do things
stand alone with very little guidance
from your project lead, just
the workload, the expectations,
the responsibilities you have
will just increase will expand
compared to these other roles.
And as an associate,
you can expect to earn
around 110,000 Euro in Germany,
again with differences company by company.
So, this is indeed a
significant salary increase
to the role that you had earlier.
Then this associate role is again
something that you will often
do for about two years or so
and then you advance and
the project lead role,
this is now the role that
you will be responsible
for consulting teams working
on the ground and the client,
typically consulting
team is the project lead
plus one to four consultants.
So, total team of two to five consultants.
And then on top of course
you'll also have the
Junior Partners, Partners,
Senior Partners who come on top
will provide some guidance
and join you occasionally.
So, as a project lead,
you can expect to 140
to 150,000 Euro base salary every year.
And then at the project lead level
with many firms also the
bonuses start to increase.
So, maybe you might have the potential
to earning approved 30%
or even more bonus on
top of your base salary
instead of maybe only 20
which was rather the norm
for the lower levels.
So, this is now the first level
where also the compensation
were very more significantly
based on your performance
that you will bring to
the table in your job.
And after the project lead role
most firms distinguished
different levels of Partner roles.
So, often it starts with
a Junior Partner level
which you will have for
another two years or so
until then you can get
elected Partner of the firm.
This is not as real full Partner role
which is often the aspiration
of many, many people
then still wanna continue
their career in consulting.
And then after four to five years
or so in your Partner role
you can become a Senior Partner,
which is then in terms of job title
the highest level that you can reach.
So, when we discuss the salaries
of these different Partner levels,
here it's important to understand
that these salary structures
are getting much more complex.
So, besides a base salary
off there is a component which is linked
to the performance of the company overall.
So, how good is the company doing overall
that you're working for?
This will affect your salary
and then also your performance element.
So, the bonus that you will
get paid on top of that
this will not pay an
increasingly important role
of your overall compensation.
But that being said as a Junior Partner,
you can then expect to earn
something about 200 to 250,000 Euro
and then once you're really
getting elected to full Partner
this will usually be above
300,000 Euro in salary.
The salary will then increase over time
again, heavily also influenced
by your performance.
Once you're a Senior Partner
this can then be rather
around 600 to 800,000 Euro
and indeed the best earning,
best performing Senior Partners
can earn in the millions.
So, will earn several
million Euro every year.
Of course, while these
figures sound very high
it's also important to understand
that it's not necessarily
easy to become Partner.
There's a so concept and idea
of the Up-or-Out Principle.
If you've never heard about that
I will link us a video above
here that I did on this topic.
So, in a nutshell, people
will get filtered out.
Many people will get
asked to leave the firm
at some point in their career.
Only the very best of course
will have the opportunity
to become Partner
and then earn salaries
in these dimensions.
So, now I'd be interested
to hear from you.
Is this surprising to you?
Does this meet your
experiences and expectations?
Do you think these
salaries are extremely high
or maybe not even that high
if you consider all the work
that goes into such a career?
Let me know your views in the comments.
And as you know I will do my very best
to answer every single
comment that you write.
So, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
please hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and also subscribe to the channel.
And especially also turn
on the notification bell
to stay up to date on all my content.
If you want to see even more from me
also follow me on Instagram,
my handle is firmlearning.
Now as always I also wanna say thank you
to all the members of the channel.
You're really making a difference,
a big contribution to the (mumbles),
to the course of this channel.
And if you're interested to
becoming a member as well,
just click on the join button
next to the subscribe button
to see how you can support
and also earn some member only perks.
To all the rest of you
thank you for watching until the very end
I'm releasing new videos
every single Saturday.
And especially also next Saturday
I have a very interesting
video planned for you.
So, stay tuned.
Good weekend to all of you.
Talk to you next Saturday.
This is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
Bye bye.